哈喽大家好
本期视频给大家介绍一个简单实用的唐奇安通道线
唐奇安通道线因海归交易法则而闻名
不知道大家是否有看过这本海归交易法则这本书
那在当年1983年
理查德丹尼斯想弄清楚交易员究竟是天生的
还是后天培养的
因此进行了交易史上最著名的一场海归交易实验
那在随后的四年当中呢
这些交易员取得了年均复利80%的收益
其中的一位交易员呢
过了保密期以后呢
给大家复盘了这场海归交易实验
写成了书
也让我们世人通过书本了解了当年
这样子的一个交易法则究竟是什么
那唐奇安通道线呢
就是海归交易法则当中的主角
技术指标
唐其安通道线呢
是由轨道线组成的
他通常帮助交易者去识别行情趋势方向
做出相应的一个交易决策
他的一个交易策略也非常简单
两种
第一个是短期
短期来说通常20日突破
我们就称为行情要开始一波新的趋势方向了
那以55日突破或者60日突破的话
那这时候我们就认为长线的一个趋势开始了
那离场离场平仓的规则也非常的简单
如果你是短线的入场
我们就以短线10日的反向突破
突破作为一个离场的规则
而如果你是长线的一个入场规则的话
那你离场是以最近的20日的反向突破
进行一个离场
看文字可能会有点枯燥
我们直接来上图
这里我直接打开的是MT4
加载的是黄金一小时周期图
在这张图上我们第一眼看到的就是上下两根红线
这个就是唐齐安通道线
在这里边上面这根线我们称之为唐齐安通道线的上轨而下面这条线我们称之为下轨这里我加载的是20日的唐前通道线
给大家去看一下
在这里边参数我选择的是20
那这个20意思就是指在过去20个小时当中
最高价和最低价
这个跟布林带不一样
那布林带通道线通常是以一个
过去20日的一个收盘价
进行一个加权平均算出来的一个值
但是这个唐前通道线最大最大的不同
就是在于它并不是去取一个平均值
而是单纯的简单的计算
从当前这根K线往前推20根K线往前推
其中最高价是多少
以及最低价是多少
那么就以黄金当前最近的这一个小时为例
那从这根K线往前推20根K线
能发现在这根20根K线里边
最高价就是这根
是不是
就是这根引线
就是这个引线
我用这个给大家标识出来
就是这根引线
那再从这根线往前推20根
最低价是不是就是这根引线
那这两个点就组成了这根K线的
上轨以及下轨的点位
能看到这个上轨的线
在这个地方
而下轨的线正好也在这个地方
非常的简单
可以说通过唐签通道线
能告诉你了
最近20日的一个潜在的支撑位
以及阻力位
那当你突破了最近20日的阻力位
以及跌破了20日的支撑位以后呢
我们就认为
潜在的趋势发生了
潜在的一个短期的趋势行情发生了
那这里边呢
我们以前面的一个行情为例
给大家去简单的复述一下
唐企安通道线的这个交易策略
也就是这个建仓规则和离场的这个规则
我们就以黄金的这一波为例
黄金的这一波行情能看到
它从这一波上去以后呢在这一个位置突破了前期的这根阻力线也就是唐齐安通道线的上轨当他突破上轨以后呢
我们就认为短期的一波趋势开始了
那这时候我们在突破的那一刻就直接选择入场
止损呢我们就放在这个下方
或者说是这根K线的下方
当然海归交易法则
它的一个止损设定并不是根据简单的裸K的结构去判断它的一个止损位置
而是通过ATR这样子的一个真实平均波幅来去动态的衡量自己的一个止损位置是在哪里的
那在这里呢我就不给大家去过度的一个复数了
有兴趣的话大家可以看我们之前关于ATR的视频
那ATR视频里面有给大家去聊如何通过ATR来进行一个止损的设定
我们这里呢
还是以简单的裸K为准
来给大家去设定一个止损
当你止损设在这根K线下方
也就是这根K线是彻底突破以后
我们的止损就设在这个位置下方
就设在这个位置
那在这个位置设置以后呢
我们就选择等待
耐心等待
那什么时候以盈利离场呢
我们看到行情这一波
突破了这根20的上回以后
确实是一路的在上行
一路上行一路上行
但是到了这里就下去
那我们具体什么时候走呢
我们在唐吉安通道线这个交易策略
刚刚给大家看了
是如果你是短线入场的话
那我们就以短线的离场为准
短线离场是最近的10日反向突破
也就是说你要在这张图里边
再加载一个10日的唐吉安通道线
好我们直接再加载一个新的唐吉安通道线
在技术指标里边找到自定义
如果您是gkfxprime解开的客户
您可以直接在自定义里面查找您是否有
我们的唐奇安通道线指标
如果您不是我们解开的客户也没有关系
您可以直接在网上搜寻唐奇安通道线的指标
一搜一大把还是挺多的
我们点击唐奇安里边这以后
我这里参数选择10
颜色也改一下免得都会看的不是很清楚我们选择绿色好了上轨和下轨都选择绿色 点击确定以后我们就能看到上轨的这根线跟前这个20的通道线呢 有高度的吻合
可以说因为行情在不断的上涨 也就是前高的这个位置不断的突破
那20日和10日的这个上轨位置通常来说会比较高度的吻合
但是下面的10日的低点位置就不一样了
我们看到绿色的低点位置
不断的不断的在往上抬高
行情在不断的往上走
但是始终没有打到这个止损位置
我们看到这根线
这根线也不算打到
因为这根线在这根收盘的时候
它的这个通道线是在这个位置的
在这个位置的
所以它并没有打到这个通道线的下沿
那行情继续的在上行
继续的上行
直到这根K线为止
跌到跌破了这根10日的绿色
我们看到绿色的下骨位置
从这一点到你入场的位置
能看到黄金你拿了44美金
所以这一波趋势可以说
很好的帮助了交易者
做出了吃到了一波
这样子的一个波段行情
可能你没有从最低点的位置
吃到最高点
从最低到最高有66美金
但是你中间的一大部分
三分之二的行情都让你吃到了
这样子的一波行情
也是会让人比较的舒服的
因为通常来说在突破行情当中
这样子的一个右侧入场
它的一个风险也会很小
相比于左侧你无脑的抄底来说
风险是小很多的
所以这就是唐奇安通道线
在海归交易法则当中的一个具体用法
那我们看最近的黄金的一小时
能看到它的上下的走势
依旧是处于20日的通道线的内部
在上下的一个震荡了
并没有形成一个彻底的破位
所以我们等待一个彻底的破位以后
我们再看一下
是否有一个很好的趋势的入场的机会